probably my favorite gambling movie is
um casino with with Joe passion De Niro
like when they're out in the desert
yelling at each other I wonder how many
takes that is like because they I I
don't I don't know how scripted that is
I mean it probably is a little bit but
like I don't I don't think you can
script the performance that Joe Pesci
does don't
[ __ ] out of me Ace yeah like I [ __ ]
brought you here yeah he's just like
pointing at the that that that energy
and they're standing there and their
friendships De Niro is like like that
that whole thing and then in the pet
yeah like that that energy what is that
I mean they must they somehow find it
together you could tell me that that was
one take and I believe you you could
tell me that that was seven takes and I
would believe I bet you all the takes
had that energy like they were playing
with it right they were they're they're
playing with that the the this yeah I
mean they they took on
a real
personality in those scenes and really
carried them forward I mean it's just a
brilliant brilliant performance it
doesn't get like comedies like mob
movies probably don't get enough credit
either
because it's seen as like mob movies
don't get enough credit not in the
Oscars I mean like that oh yeah yeah
yeah because it seems like a Trope it's
like giving a western uh it's got to be
a hell of a western or whatever because
it's like an old Hollywood Trope yeah no
I that scene is so great because they're
never there at the height of their
friendship in a way and they're also
pretty much about to let go of it and
become enemies and both things are
happening at the same time and and Pesci
drives him out to the desert and if I
remember correctly
De Niro's character eighth Ace rostin
Rothschild he says I I gave myself 50 50
whether I'm coming back yeah it's such a
good scene
usually my prospects of coming back from
the desert would be 90 to 10 or
something like that but now it's this
time I wasn't sure and there's the car
driving really fast and then Joe pesh is
like you [ __ ] you like whatever
he was doing yeah a Jew I think of
course is anti-Semitism yeah we're not
between friends
who gives a [ __ ] all that kind of stuff
yeah I mean brilliant brilliant
performances so yeah I I can understand
why you love the art and putting it all
out there